i am fascinated with discussing how it  is to be single in this modern age yeah  well i mean the last two years was it's  not an easy time to be single and also  dating in new york like i've never i'm  english and the whole concept of dating  in america is so different over there  like yourself if you kiss someone in  england you're basically together like  this whole i'm dating a few people thing  i'm like god what is happening how does  anybody manage that like i must be  british you've got to go to england yes  yes i am i'm not a juggler no um if i  met someone on a dating app and we like  said hello i'm like oh we're together  now and i shouldn't  even talk to someone else on the dating  app because the guy who like owns it is  watching me yes and he'll know and i  can't do that